for most people thinking about money all
day long is two words fun or exciting
and in fact it's quite stressful the
standard of what I want to see built I
don't believe that there's a company
that is close there's a couple united
states that's starting to think about
this and in doing a good job also called
tally where the jason the founder is
wonderful
and it you know he he was helping people
he started with credit card debt pay off
the credit card debt faster which was
the court clean point and starting
automation around it but um you know I
think I want to I want to like
fast-forward the decade ahead where we
actually get to Instant Streaming money
it you know I call it liquefied money
you're calling it streaming money where
your money can always be optimizing to
the right place and that gets pretty
powerful when that begins to happen but
most importantly not only is it powerful
it meaningfully changes the life of
American families oh yeah I've heard
this idea before about basically hey
what's a category of what you built it's
like P P P F am something like that yeah
pfm personal finance manager and the
theory is basically you have things that
clarity money and learn vast and others
that were basically all like hey we can
suggest some things we can show you some
charts and analysis but like
fundamentally you the user make the
decision and what you're talking about
is the software makes the decision right
self-driving basically like it's not
it's not you're sitting in your car and
your car suggests to you how you should
you know turn or change lanes the car
changes lanes because it knows where
you're trying to get is your destination
and so I've heard before that hey what
we need is for to get get AI basically
to the point where it can actually make
the decisions and optimize the money for
you so that the user doesn't have to
make decisions user says I want I have
these financial goals for myself this is
my income coming in here's my bills and
it basically does it and what I've what
you added on was the reason that can't
happen right now is because the transfer
is too slow but it seems like there's a
middle step
just right now the software doesn't
decide the user decides and most users
don't want to think about that or make
those decisions that most people are not
active with their money management much
to your chagrin I'm sure so is it more
about software deciding versus users
deciding or is it more about liquefied
money so liquefied money matters but
then to your point so I'm gonna like I
want to answer that with a with a visual
question when we imagine money right now
we imagine money by saying okay I'm
gonna log into my you know my etrade
account and I'm gonna stare it on my
grass and and you know look at things
and I'm in a top to an advisor and tell
them my goals and then like a lot of
things are gonna be executed I almost
think that we are thinking about the
limits in the sound of what technology
offers today as opposed to what the
customer really wants if you ask the
customer what they really want they want
enough money to do what they need to do
and they want everything else to be
taken care of and like for most people
thinking about money all day long
there's a sort of fun or exciting and in
fact it's quite stressful I'm so imagine
and so I almost think we visualize money
based on what exists but imagine a
thought exercise and I'll use an Amazon
Alexa since I literally there's like 17
in my brother's house and he just likes
to yell at me all day anything's it's so
funny but basically let's use an Amazon
Alexa and imagine you could walk in your
kitchen every morning and just say you
have surveillance so you've rules that
you've set it around your wallet so has
anyone broken my identity has anyone
done anything bad or on tour
restrictions that you put on to like my
kids credit cards can eat only you know
spend fifty dollars a month and whatever
it may be and then you've already
clearly laid out goals and it just does
it for you and so you walk in like why
do I even need to look at my money all I
care about is are there any crises no
are the rules I've set up in place so
any extra money you know I need four
hundred dollars in my savings account
for checking for you know if I need cash
we're gonna obviously go away from cash
permanently at some point um and then
everything else just optimize for me and
that's math the thing I love you know I
am a math geek I've all
liked math growing up I always loved it
math is really beautiful because this
isn't you know we're not trying to cure
something a disease that we don't this
isn't a kovat situation where we don't
know that we don't know what to do yet
we are looking for a vaccine to use that
as an analogy this is math for every
American wallet I can mathematically
tell you where their next dollar should
go to save to save them money make their
life better and outside of them telling
us what their goals are then the math
can do it and it can do it every hour or
every minute and at some point when you
get there that is better for the
American rollit and so that's the vision
of that's literally the picture in the
back of my head is like when do we get
to a place where my money is just doing
what it should do at all times and right
now there's wild amounts of friction
move it from here put it in the savings
account sweep it into this do this with
this pay off the credit card to pay off
your student loans you have to make two
payments and tell them please pay the
principal not just the intern friction
everywhere and at some point it will go
away and I motto services be candid it
will be selling my life Doris you're
very uh persuasive I feel like I'm ready
to like get behind you and say let's go
to war you're very you've got a very
good
[Music]